[Musica]
[Applauso]
bene o male a voi arrivato qualcosa Vi è
arrivato il suono
Ma questa è stata la vostra prospettiva
perché per me c'è stata un'altra cosa ci
sono state le vibrazioni le vibrazioni
derivanti da contatto con lo strumento
perché io sono nata sciorda ho una
sordità congenita dalla nascita
per cui
diciamo nel corso della mia vita Ho
fatto un percorso per imparare a tirare
fuori i suoni non solo dello strumento
ma anche quello della mia voce
perché fino ad oltre 50 anni fa le
persone che avevano un problema di udito
nascevano con un problema di udito non
avevano la possibilità anche di imparare
a parlare forse anche a leggere a
scrivere e quindi ho avuto in realtà la
possibilità di uscire dal silenzio e
l'ho chiamato il silenzio potenziale
perché c'era appunto il potenziale
e diciamo che il mio percorso Perché la
vita è fatta di percorsi
ha visto nella scena di figure le figure
che sono state importanti per la mia
vita
quindi volevo parlarvi Innanzitutto Che
cosa significa non sentire i suoni vi
presento una diagramma audiometrico
diagramma che si usa anche per fare i
test a due metri sulle l'udito in cui
sono collocati i suoni che si misurano
in decibel lascio il laser o la soglia
dell'udito normale e Poi man mano che si
va giù scende e la perdita uditiva
diventa più importante la donna grigia è
l'area del parlato dove si collocano le
lettere le parole e quando siamo sotto
quella soglia c'è un problema e infatti
la mia albiometria è molto bassa parte
da 90 decibel in giù
E allora i miei genitori
all'epoca dovevano chiedersi che cosa
fare
e quindi oggi ho dovuto iniziare un
percorso che grazie anche al fatto che
loro hanno avuto una prospettiva la
prospettiva di un percorso che mi
avrebbe aiutata a fare una vita del
tutto normale è già stata una signora
importante che diceva che in sciordi gli
sentono le vibrazioni quindi dalla
vibrazione poi si arriva al suono e alla
parola questa signora si chiama giù la
cremaschi-trevesi e per oltre 50 anni ha
dedicato la sua vita a fare uscire dal
silenzio tre generazioni di non udenti
per lei è stata una scoperta ha dovuto
cambiare appunto la prospettiva dovuto
rompere tutti i suoi schermi tutto
quello che credeva prima sulla musica
sulla sul suono sulla parola in questa
immagine noi vediamo che la lavorava coi
bambini c'è una bambina sorda che sta
secondo posto a partire da destra e la
li metteva sul pianoforte e giocava con
questi bambini
si chiedeva Ma questi loro ballano e
rispondono alla mia musica sopra sotto
il pianoforte
ed era fermo
Quindi i miei genitori mi portarono da
questa signora questa signora disse che
c'era uno strumento più indicato per il
tipo di sordità che avevo appunto il
violoncello perché ha i suoni bassi
gravi
mentre io perdo completamente la tutti
Allora iniziai a fare una scuola di
musica e mi diedero in mano un
violoncello
e il violoncello copre tutte le
frequenze della voce umana
eccetto magari la voce sopranno che va
un po' oltre Però a una estensione molto
ampia
io però ho dovuto
escogitare un sistema per superare un
limite un ostacolo che era quello
dell'intonazione perché l'intonazione
sullo strumento ad Arco è una delle cose
più difficili da fare è difficile per
una persona che che sente bene
figuriamoci proprio per una persona che
non sente e io però oltre 30 anni ho
cercato di capire l'intonazione Cercava
proprio di scovare Qual era la cosa che
mi impediva di capire che cosa fosse
quindi ero davanti a un limite che
dovevo superare 30 anni dopo perché
purtroppo è una cosa recente che ho
inventato solo l'anno scorso ho
inventato il brillescello ho trovato
questo sistema
di tasti in rilievo che mi permettono di
sfruttare al meglio le vibrazioni quindi
sento bene sulle dita dove appoggio il
tasto Luciano differente da dalla
chitarra o da qualsiasi altro strumento
e quindi questo mi ha permesso di
superare l'ostacolo superare il limite
E questa signora utilizzava la musica
per arrivare poi alla parola e una
persona che non sente
riusciamo che percepisce un dialogo una
frase in maniera un po'
così lacunosa perché ci sono delle
lacune delle lettere delle parole che
non si riescono a sentire bene e quindi
abbiamo fatto un esempio di come
potrebbe essere
percepita una frase
ci sono diverse lettere mancanti e
quindi diventa come un gioco
dell'impeccato usare molto
l'immaginazione l'intuito Il sesto senso
erano ineducabili perché l'orecchio è
l'organo dell'educazione e i fiordi sono
anche privi di intelligenza perché
questa si costruisce grazie alla parola
a cui fiordino accedono e quindi di cui
io vi metto in guardia anche qua
l'abbiamo grandi personaggi grandi
pensatori del passato e magari non
sempre dicono le cose giuste per cui
bisogna anche capire che
quella che noi chiamiamo anche
intelligenza qualche intelligenza
potenziale non deve essere mai
accompagnata da arroganza produzione Io
credo che l'intelligenza sia una cosa
molto più umile di quella che pensiamo
e quando dobbiamo cercare una soluzione
Un intuizione dobbiamo ritrovare il
silenzio
Easy Life se c'è molto utile in questo
show di ballavano anche quando non c'era
la musica Perché quando Io ascolto la
radio in macchina ti metto una musica
poi a un certo punto la musica finisce e
inizia a parlare il cronista o il
presentatore io non mi sono non mi
accorgo Un tempo era così non mi
accorgevo quando era finita la musica e
continuava a sentire musica
perché questo La Qualunque Suono anche
anche sui suoni che sentiamo in strada i
rumori se lo sempre la musica che noi
abbiamo dentro
e i sordi sono Golosi di suoni diceva la
Cara maestra Giulia è davvero perché
quando i suoni
diventano una scoperta qualcosa che ci
manca ci viene voglia anche di conoscere
e di scoprire
noi è passato avevamo sperimentato
l'esclusione cioè tutti i soci oggetti
che erano diversi nella società venivano
esclusi e poi pian piano sono stati
integrati però con percorsi differenti
questo ancora non è tanto bello da fare
oggi perché la vera inclusione comporta
che tutti abbiano le stesse possibilità
le stesse potenzialità
e quindi potenziale è presente in
chiunque in ogni persona che deve
intraprendere un percorso
viene a cercare l'unicità nell'ordinario
includere e interagire perché questo Poi
porta a delle nuove scoperte e i limiti
nascondono sempre il potenziale bisogna
attendere le intuizioni senza fretta
curare e proteggere il seme per farlo
sbocciare insieme parliamo magari anche
dei bambini o persone che ancora devono
trovare la loro strada e al loro
percorso e collaborare
che Questo poi diventa una società più
matura e che può progredire
facile vi saluto e vi lascio con
un video in cui io suono insieme a
Filippo con pianista cieco io cieco e io
sono sorda
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]